The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we've been talking
about this chi square test.
And the name chi square
comes from the fact
that we build a
test statistic that
has asymptotic
distribution given
by the chi square distribution.
Let's just give it another shot.
OK.
This test.
Who has actually ever
encountered the chi square test
outside of a stats classroom?
All right.
So some people have.
It's a fairly common test
that you might encounter.
And it was essentially
to test, if given
some data with a fixed
probability mass function, so
a discrete
distribution, you wanted
to test if the PMF was
equal to a set value, p0,
or if it was different from p0.
And the way the chi
square arose here
was by looking at Wald's test.
And essentially if you write--
so Wald's is the one that
has the chi square as the
limiting distribution,
and if you invert the
covariance matrix,
the asymptotic covariance
matrix, so you compute
the Fisher information,
which in this particular case
does not exist for the
multinomial distribution,
but we found the trick
on how to do this.
We remove the part that
forbid it to be invertible,
then we found this chi
square distribution.
In a way we have
this test statistic,
which you might have learned
as a black box, laundry list,
but going through the math
which might have been slightly
unpleasant, I acknowledge,
but really told you
why you should do this
particular normalization.
So since some of you requested
a little more practical examples
of how those things work,
let me show you a couple.
The first one is you want to
answer the question, well,
you know, when should I
be born to be successful.
Some people believe in zodiac,
and so Fortune magazine
actually collected the signs of
256 heads of the Fortune 500.
Those were taken randomly.
And they were collected
there, and you
can see the count of
number of CEOs that
have a particular zodiac sign.
And if this was completely
uniformly distributed,
you should actually
get a number that's
around 256 divided by 12,
which in this case is 21.33.
And you can see that
there is numbers
that are probably in the
vicinity, but look at this guy.
Pisces, that's 29.
So who's Pisces here?
All right.
All right, so give
me your information
and we'll meet
again in 10 years.
And so basically you
might want to test
if actually the fact that
it's uniformly distributed
is a valid assumption.
Now this is clearly
a random variable.
I pick a random
CEO and I measure
what his zodiac sign is.
And I want to know, so it's a
probability over, I don't know,
12 zodiac signs.
And I want to know if
it's uniform or not.
Uniform sounds like it
should be the status
quo, if you're reasonable.
And maybe there's actually
something that moves away.
So we could do this, in view
of these data is there evidence
that one is different.
Here is another example
where you might want
to apply the chi square test.
So as I said, the
benchmark distribution
was the uniform distribution
for the zodiac sign,
and that's usually
the one I give you.
1 over k, 1 over k,
because well that's
sort of the zero, the central
point for all distributions.
That's the point, the center
of what we call the simplex.
But you can have
another benchmark
that sort of makes sense.
So for example this is an actual
dataset where 275 jurors were
identified, racial
group were collected,
and you actually
might want to know
if you know juries
in this country
are actually representative
of the actual population.
And so here of
course, the population
is not uniformly distributed
according to racial group.
And the way you
actually do it is you
actually go on
Wikipedia, for example,
and you look at the demographics
of the United States,
and you find that the proportion
of white is 72%, black is 7%,
Hispanic is 12, and
other is about 9%.
So that's a total of 1.
And this is what we actually
measured for some jurors.
So for this guy,
you can actually
run the chi square test.
You have the estimated
proportion, which
comes from this first line.
You have the tested
proportion, p0,
that comes from the
second line, and you
might want to check if
those things actually
correspond to each other.
OK, so I'm not going
to do it for you,
but I sort of
invite you to do it
and test, and see
how this compares
to the quantiles of
the appropriate chi
square distribution and see what
you can conclude from those two
things.
All right.
So this was the
multinomial case.
So this is essentially
what we did.
We computed the MLE under
the right constraint,
and that was our test
statistic that converges
to the chi square distribution.
So if you've seen
it before, that's
all that was given to you.
Now we know why the
normalization here
is p0 j and not p0 j squared or
square root of p0 j, or even 1.
I mean it's not clear
that this should
be the right
normalization, but we
know that's what
comes from taking
the right normalization,
which comes from the Fisher
information.
All right?
OK.
The thing I wanted to move
onto, so we've basically covered
chi square test.
Are there any questions
about chi square test?
And for those of you who
were not here on Thursday,
I'm really just--
do not pretend I just did it.
That's something we
did last Thursday.
But are there any
questions that arose
when you were reading
your notes, things
that you didn't understand?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
like a formal name?
Before we had talked about
how what we call the Fisher
information [INAUDIBLE],,
still has the same [INAUDIBLE]
because it's the same number.
PROFESSOR: So it's
not the Fisher.
The Fisher information does
not exist in this case.
And so there's no
appropriate name for this.
It's the pseudoinverse of the
asymptotic covariance matrix,
and that's what it is.
I don't know if I
mentioned it last time,
but there's this entire
field that uses--
you know, for people who really
aspire to differential geometry
but are stuck in the
stats department,
and there's this thing called
information geometry, which
is essentially studying
the manifolds associated
to the Fisher information
metric, the metric that's
associated to
Fisher information.
And so those of course can be
lower dimensional manifolds,
not only distorts the
geometry but forces everything
to live on a lower
dimension, which
is what happens when your Fisher
information does not exist.
And so there's a bunch
of things that you
can study, what this manifold
looks like, et cetera.
But no, there's no
particular terminology here
about going here.
To be fair, within the
scope of this class,
this is the only
case where you--
multinomial case
is the only case
where you typically see a lack
of a Fisher information matrix.
And that's just because we
have these extra constraints
that the sum of the
parameters should be 1.
And if you have an
extra constraint that
seems like it's actually
remove one degree of freedom,
this will happen inevitably.
And so maybe what you
can do is reparameterize.
So if I actually reparameterize
everything function of p1
to p k minus 1, and
then 1 minus the sum,
this would not have happened.
Because I have only a
k-dimensional space.
So there's tricks
around this to make it
exist if you want it to exist.
Any other question?
All right.
So let's move on to
Student's t-test.
We mentioned it last time.
So essentially you've
probably done it
more even in the homework than
you've done it in lectures,
but just quickly this
is essentially the test.
That's the test when we have
an actual data that comes
from a normal distribution.
There is no Central Limit
Theorem that exists.
This is really to
account for the fact
that for smaller
sample sizes, it
might be the case that it's
not exactly true that when
I look at xn bar minus mu
divided by-- so if I look
at xn bar minus mu divided by
sigma times square root of n,
then this thing should have N
0, 1 distribution approximately.
Right?
By the Central Limit Theorem.
So that's for n large.
But if n is small,
then it's still true
when the data is N
mu, sigma squared,
then it's true that
square root of n--
so here it's approximately.
And this is always true.
But I don't know sigma
in practice, right?
Maybe mu, it comes from my,
maybe mu comes from my mu
0, maybe something
from the test statistic
where mu actually is here.
But for this guy I'm
going to have inevitably
to find an estimator.
And now in this case, for small
n, this is no longer true.
And what the t
statistic is doing
is essentially telling you what
the distribution of this guy
is.
So what you should say
is that now this guy
has a t distribution with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom.
That's basically the
laundry list stats
that you would learn.
It says just look at a different
table, that's what it is.
But we actually defined
what a t distribution was.
And a t distribution
is basically
something that has the same
distribution as some N 0, 1,
divided by the square
root of a chi square
with d degrees of
freedom divided by d.
And that's a t distribution
with d degrees of freedom.
And those two have
to be independent.
And so what I need to check
is that this guy over there
is of this form.
OK?
So let's look at the numerator.
Well, square root of
n, xn bar minus mu.
What is the distribution
of this thing?
Is it an N 0, 1?
AUDIENCE: N 0, sigma squared?
PROFESSOR: N 0,
sigma squared, right.
So I'm not going to put it here.
So if I want this
guy to be N 0, 1,
I need to divide by sigma,
that's what we have over there.
So that's my N 0, 1 that's going
to play the role of this guy
here.
So if I want to go
a little further,
I need to just say, OK, now I
need to have square root of n,
and I need to find
something here
that looks like my square
root of chi square divided
by-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Really quick question.
The equals sign with the d on
top, that's just defined as?
PROFESSOR: No, that's
just the distribution.
So, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Then never mind.
PROFESSOR: Let's just write
it like that, if you want.
I mean, that's not really
appropriate to have.
Usually you write
only one distribution
on the right-hand inside
of this little thing.
So not just this complicated
function of distributions.
This is more like to explain.
OK, and so usually
the thing you should
say that t is equal to this
X divided by square root of Z
divided by d where X
has normal distribution,
Z has chi square distribution
with d degrees of freedom.
So what do we need here?
Well I need to have something
which looks like my sigma hat,
right?
So somehow inevitably I'm going
to need to have sigma hat.
Now of course I need to
divide this by my sigma
so that my sigma goes away.
And so now this thing here--
sorry, I should move
on to the right, OK.
And so this thing here, so
sigma hat is square root of Sn.
And now I'm almost there.
So this thing is actually
equal to square root of n.
But this thing here
is actually not a--
so this thing here
follows a distribution
which is actually a
chi square, square root
of a chi square
distribution divided by n.
Yeah, that's the square
root chi square distribution
with n minus 1 degrees
of freedom divided
by n, because sigma hat
is equal to 1 over n sum
from i equal 1 to n,
xi minus x bar squared.
And we just said
that this part here
was a chi square distribution.
We didn't just say it, we said
it a few lectures years back,
that this thing was a chi square
distribution, and the fact
that the presence
of this x bar here
was actually removing one
degree of freedom from this sum.
OK, so this guy here has
the same distribution
as a chi square n
minus 1 divided by n.
So I need to actually still
arrange this thing a little bit
to have a t distribution.
I should not see n here,
but I should n minus 1.
The d is the same
as this d here.
And so let me make
the correction
so that this actually happens.
Well, if I actually write
this to be equal to--
so if I write square root of
n minus 1, as on the slide,
times xn bar minus
mu divided by--
well let me write it
as square root of Sn,
which is my sigma hat.
Then what this thing
is actually equal to,
it follows a N 0, 1,
divided by the square root
of my chi square
distribution with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom.
And here the fact
that I multiply
by square root of
n minus 1, and I
have the square root of n
here, is essentially the same
as dividing here by n minus 1.
And that's my tn distribution.
My t distribution with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom.
Just by definition of
what this thing is.
OK?
All right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where'd you
get the square root from?
PROFESSOR: This guy?
Oh sorry, that's sigma squared.
Thank you.
That's the estimator of the
variance, not the estimator
of the standard deviation.
And when I want to divide it I
divide by standard deviation.
Thank you.
Any other question or remark?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't you
divide by sigma squared?
The actual.
The estimator for
the variance is
equal to sigma squared
times chi square, right?
PROFESSOR: The estimator
for the variance.
Oh yes, you're right.
So there's a sigma squared here.
Is that what you're asking?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yes, absolutely.
And that's where,
it get cancels here.
It gets canceled here.
OK?
So this is really a sigma
squared times chi square.
OK.
So the fact that
it's sigma squared
is just because I
can pull out sigma
squared and just think
those guys N 0, 1.
All right.
So that's my t distribution.
Now that I actually have a
pivotal distribution, what I do
is that I form the statistic.
Here I called it Tn tilde.
OK.
And what is this thing?
I know that this has a
pivotal distribution.
So for example, I know
that the probability
that Tn tilde in absolute value
exceeds some number that I'm
going to call q alpha over
2 for the t n minus 1,
is equal to alpha.
So that's basically,
remember the t distribution
has the same shape as the
Gaussian distribution.
What I'm finding is,
for this t distribution,
some number q alpha
over 2 of t n minus 1
and minus q alpha
over 2 of t minus 1.
So those are different
from the Gaussian one.
Such that the area
under the curve
here is alpha over
2 on each side
so that the probability that
my absolute value exceeds
this number is equal to alpha.
And that's what I'm going
to use to reject the test.
So now my test becomes, for H0,
say mu is equal to some mu 0,
versus H1, mu is
not equal to mu 0.
The rejection region is going
to be equal to the set on which
square root of n minus 1 times
xn bar minus mu 0 this time,
divided by square root of Sn
exceeds, in absolute value,
exceeds q-- sorry
that's already here--
exceeds q alpha over
2 of t n minus 1.
So I reject when
this thing increases.
The same as the Gaussian case,
except that rather than reading
my quantiles from
the Gaussian table
I read them from
the Student table.
It's just the same thing.
So they're just going to
be a little bit farther.
So this guy here is just
going to be a little bigger
than the one for
the Gaussian one,
because it's going to require
me a little more evidence
in my data to be able
to reject because I
have to account for the
fluctuations of sigma hat.
So of course Student's
test is used everywhere.
People use only t tests, right?
If you look at any
data point, any output,
even if you had
500 observations,
if you look at the
statistical software output
it's going to say t test.
And the reason
why you see t test
is because somehow it's felt
like it's not asymptotic.
You don't need to
actually do, you
know, to be
particularly careful.
And anyway, if n
is equal to 500,
since the two curves
are above each other
it's basically the same thing.
So it doesn't really
change anything.
So why not use the t test?
So it's not asymptotic.
It doesn't require Central
Limit Theorem to kick in.
And so in particular it be run
if you have 15 observations.
Of course, the drawback
of the Student test
is that it relies
on the assumption
that the sample is Gaussian,
and that's something
we really need to keep in mind.
If you have a small sample size,
there is no magic going on.
It's not like Student t
test allows you to get rid
of this asymptotic normality.
It sort of assumes
that it's built in.
It assumes that your data
has a Gaussian distribution.
So if you have 15 observations,
what are you going to do?
You want to test if the mean is
equal to 0 or not equal to 0,
but you have only
15 observations.
You have to somehow assume
that your data is Gaussian.
But if the data is given
to you, this is not math,
you actually have to
check that it's Gaussian.
And so we're going
to have to find
a test that, given some data,
tells us whether it's Gaussian
or not.
If I have 15
observations, 8 of them
are equal to plus 1 and 7 of
them are equal to minus 1,
then it's pretty
unlikely that you're
going to be able to conclude
that your data has a Gaussian
distribution.
However, if you see some sort
of spread around some value,
you form a histogram
maybe and it sort of
looks like it's a
Gaussian, you might
want to say it's Gaussian.
And so how do we make
this more quantitative?
Well, the sad answer
to this question
is that there will be some
tests that make it quantitative,
but here, if you think about it
for one second, what is going
to be your null hypothesis?
Your null hypothesis,
since it's one point,
it's going to be
that it's Gaussian,
and then the
alternative is going
to be that it's not Gaussian.
So what it means is
that, for the first time
in your statistician
life, you're
going to want to conclude
that H0 is the true one.
You're definitely
not going to want
to say that it's not Gaussian,
because then everything you
know is sort of falling apart.
And so it's kind of
a weird thing where
you're sort of going
to be seeking tests
that have no power basically.
You're going to want to test
that, and that's the nature.
The amount of
alternatives, the number
of ways you can be not
Gaussian, is so huge
that all tests are sort of
bound to have very low power.
And so that's why people are
pretty happy with the idea
that things are
Gaussian, because it's
very hard to find
a test that's going
to reject this hypothesis.
And so we're even going to find
some tests that are visual,
where you're going
to be able to say,
well, sort of looks
Gaussian to me.
It allows you to deal
with the borderline cases
pretty efficiently.
We'll see actually a
particular example.
All right, so this
theory of testing
whether data comes from
a particular distribution
is called goodness of fit.
Is this distribution a
good fit for my data?
That's the goodness of fit test.
We have just seen a
goodness of fit test.
What was it?
Yeah.
The chi square test, right?
The case square test, we
were given a candidate PMF
and we were testing if this
was a good fit for our data.
That was a goodness of fit test.
So of course multinomial
is one example,
but really what we have
in the back of our mind is
I want to test if
my data is Gaussian.
That's basically
the usual thing.
And just like you always see
t test as the standard output
from statistical software
whether you ask for it or not,
there will be a
test for normality
whether you ask it or not from
any statistical software app.
All right.
So a goodness of fit
test looks as follows.
There's a random
variable X and you're
given i.i.d. copies
of X, X1 to Xn,
they come from the
same distribution.
And you're going to ask the
following question: does X have
a standard normal distribution?
So for t distribution
that's definitely
the kind of questions
you may want to ask.
Does X have a uniform
distribution on 0, 1?
That's different from
the distribution 1
over k, 1 over k, it's
the continuous notion
of uniformity.
And for example, you
might want to test that--
so there's actually a
nice exercise, which
is if you look at the p-values.
So we've defined what
the p-values were.
And the p-value's a number
between 0 and 1, right?
And you could
actually ask yourself,
what is the distribution of
the p-value under the null?
So the p-value is
a random number.
It's the probability-- so
the p-value-- let's look
at the following test.
H0, mu is equal to 0, versus
H1, mu is not equal to 0.
And I know that the p-value is--
so I'm going to form what?
I'm going to look
at Xn bar minus mu
times square root of n
divided by-- let's say that we
know sigma for one second.
Then the p-value
is the probability
that this is larger then
square root of n little xn
bar minus mu, minus 0
actually in this case,
divided by sigma, where
this guy is the observed.
OK.
So now you could say, well,
how is that a random variable?
It's just a number.
It's just a probability
of something.
But then I can view this
as a function of this guy
here when I plug it back
to be a random variable.
So what I mean by this is
that if I look at this value
here, if I say that phi
is the CDF of N 0, 1,
so the p-value is
the probability
that it exceeds this.
So that's the probability
that I'm either here or here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, it's not, right?
PROFESSOR: This is a big
X and this is a small x.
This is just where
you plug in your data.
The p-value is the
probability that you
have more evidence
against your null
than what you already have.
OK, so now I can
write it in terms
of cumulative
distribution functions.
So this is what?
This is phi of this guy, which
is minus this thing here.
Well it's basically
2 times this guy,
phi of minus square root of
n, Xn bar divided by sigma.
That's my p-value.
If you give me data, I'm
going to compute the average
and plug it in there, and
it can spit out the p-value.
Everybody agrees?
So now I can view this, if I
start now looking back I say,
well, where does
this data come from?
Well, it could be
a random variable.
It came from the
realization of this thing.
So I can try to, I can
think of this value,
where now this is a random
variable because I just plugged
in a random variable in here.
So now I view my p-value
as a random variable.
So I keep switching from
small x to large X. Everybody
agrees what I'm doing here?
So I just wrote it as a
deterministic function
of some deterministic
number, and now the function
stays deterministic but
the number becomes random.
And so I can think of this
as some statistic of my data.
And I could say, well,
what is the distribution
of this random variable?
Now if my data is actually
normally distributed,
so I'm actually
under the null, so
under the null, that means that
Xn bar times square root of n
divided by sigma has
what distribution?
Normal?
Well it was sigma,
I assume I knew it.
So it's N 0, 1, right?
I divided by sigma here.
OK?
So now I have this
random variable.
And so my random variable is now
2 phi of minus absolute value
of a Gaussian.
And I'm actually interested in
the distribution of this thing.
I could ask that.
Anybody has an idea
of how you would
want to tackle this thing?
If I ask you, what
is the distribution
of a random variable, how
do you tackle this question?
There's basically two ways.
One is to try to
find something that
looks like the expectation
of h of x for all h.
And you try to write this
using change of variables
and something that looks like
integral of h of x p of x dx.
And then you say, well,
that's the density.
If you can read this
for any h, then that's
the way you would do it.
But there's a simpler
way that does not
involve changing
variables, et cetera,
you just try to compute
the cumulative distribution
function.
So let's try to
compute the probability
that 2 phi minus N
0, 1, is less than t.
And maybe we can find
something we know.
OK.
Well that's equal to what?
That's the probability
that a minus N 0,
well let's say that an N 0, 1--
sorry, N 0, 1 absolute value is
greater than minus phi inverse
of t over 2.
And that's what?
Well, it's just the same
thing that we had before.
It's equal to-- so
if I look again,
this is the probability that
I'm actually on this side
or that side of this number.
And this number is what?
It's minus phi of t over 2.
Why do I have a minus here?
That's fine, OK.
So it's actually not this,
it's actually the probability
that my absolute value--
oh, because phi inverse.
OK.
Because phi inverse is--
so I'm going to
look at t between 0
and-- so this number is
ranging between 0 and 1.
So it means that this number
is ranging between 0--
well, the probability that
something is less than t
should be ranging between the
numbers that this guy takes,
so that's between 0 and 2.
Because this thing takes
values between 0 and 2.
I want to see 0 and 1, though.
AUDIENCE: Negative absolute
value is always less
than [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're right, thank you.
So this is always some
number which is less than 0,
so the probability that
the Gaussian is less
than this number is always
less than the probability
it's less than 0,
which is 1/2, so t only
has to be between 0 and 1.
Thank you.
And so now for t
between 0 and 1, then
this guy is actually becoming
something which is positive,
for the same reason as before.
And so that's what?
That's just basically 2 times
phi of phi inverse of t over 2.
That's just playing with
the symmetry a little bit.
You can look at the
areas under the curve.
And so what it means is
that those two guys cancel.
This is the identity.
And so this is equal to t.
So which distribution
has a density--
sorry, which distribution
has a cumulative distribution
function which is equal to
t for t between 0 and 1?
That's the uniform
distribution, right?
So it means that this guy
follows a uniform distribution
on the interval 0, 1.
And you could
actually check that.
For any test you're
going to come up with,
this is going to be the case.
Your p-value under the null
will have a distribution
which is uniform.
So now if somebody shows up
and says, here's my test,
it's awesome, it
just works great.
I'm not going to explain
to you how I built it,
it's a complicated
statistics that
involve moments of order 27.
And I'm like, OK,
you know, how am I
going to test that your test
statistic actually makes sense?
Well one thing I can do
is to run a bunch of data,
draw a bunch of samples,
compute your test statistic,
compute the p-value, and
check if my p-value has
a uniform distribution
on the interval 0, 1.
But for that I need
to have a test that,
given a bunch of
observations, can tell me
whether they're actually
distributed uniformly
on the interval 0, 1.
And again one thing I could
do is build a histogram
and see if it looks
like that of a uniform,
but I could also try to be
slightly more quantitative
about this.
AUDIENCE: Why does
the [INAUDIBLE] have
to be for a [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For two tests?
AUDIENCE: For each test.
Why does the p-value
have to be normal?
I mean, uniform.
PROFESSOR: It's
uniform under the null.
So because my test statistic
was built under the null,
and so I have to be able to plug
in the right value in there,
otherwise it's going
to shift everything
for this particular test.
AUDIENCE: At the beginning
while your probabilities
were of big Xn, that thing.
That thing is the p-value.
PROFESSOR: That's
the p-value, right?
That's the definition
of the p-value.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So it's
the probability
that my test statistic exceeds
what I've actually observed.
AUDIENCE: So how you run
the test is basically
you have your
observations and plug them
into the cumulative distribution
function for a normal,
and then see if it
falls under the given--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So my p-value is
just this number
when I just plug in the
values that I observe here.
That's one number.
For every dataset
you're going to give me,
it's going to be one number.
Now what I can do is generate
a bunch of datasets of size n,
like 200 of them.
And then I'm going
to have a new sample
of say 200, which is just
the sample of 200 p-values.
And I want to test if
those p-values have
a uniform distribution.
OK?
Because that's the distribution
they should be having.
All right?
OK.
This one we've already seen.
Does x have a PMF with
30%, 50%, and 20%?
That's something I
could try to test.
That looks like your grade point
distribution for this class.
Well not exactly, but
that looks like it.
So all these things are known
as goodness of fit tests.
The goodness of fit
test is something
that you want to know if the
data that you have at hand
follows the hypothesized
distribution.
So it's not a parametric test.
It's not a test that says, is
my mean equal to 25 or not.
Is my proportion of heads
larger than 1/2 or not?
It's something that
says, my distribution
this particular thing.
So I'm going to write them as
goodness of fit, G-O-F here.
You don't need to have
parametric modeling to do that.
So how do I work?
So if I don't have any
parametric modeling,
I need to have something which
is somewhat non-parametric,
something that goes
beyond computing the mean
and the standard
deviation, something
that computes some intrinsic
non-parametric aspect
of my data.
And just like here we made
this computation, what we did
is we said well,
if I actually check
that the CDF of my data,
that my p-value is uniform,
then I know it's uniform.
So it means that the cumulative
distribution function
has an intrinsic value
about it that captures
the entire distribution.
Everything I need to know
about my distribution
is captured by the cumulative
distribution function.
Now I have an empirical
way of computing,
I have a data-driven
way of computing
an estimate for the cumulative
distribution function, which
is using the old
statistical trick which
consists of replacing
expectations by averages.
So as I said, the cumulative
distribution function
for any distribution, for
any random variable, is--
so F of t is the
probability that X
is less than or
equal to t, which
is equal to the expectation
of the indicator
that X is less
than or equal to t.
That's the definition
of a probability.
And so here I'm just going
to replace expectation
by the average.
That's my usual
statistical trick.
And so my estimator Fn for--
the distribution is going
to be 1 over n sum from i
equal 1 to n of
these indicators.
And this is called
the empirical CDF.
It's just the data
version of the CDF.
So I just replaced this
expectation here by an average.
Now when I sum
indicators, I'm actually
counting the number of them
that satisfy something.
So if you look at
what this guy is,
this is the number of X i's
that is less than t, right?
And so if I divide by n, it's
the proportion of observations
I have that are less than t.
That's what the empirical
distribution is.
That's what's written here,
the number of data points
that are less than t.
And so this is going
to be something
that's sort of trying to
estimate one or the other.
And the law of large
number actually
tells me that for any given t,
if n is large enough, Fn of t
should be close to F of t.
Because it's an average.
And this entire thing, this
entire statistical trick,
which consists of replacing
expectations by averages,
is justified by the
law of large number.
Every time we used it, that was
because the law of large number
sort of guaranteed to
us that the average was
close to the expectation.
OK.
So law of large numbers tell
me that Fn of t converges,
so that's the strong law, says
that almost surely actually
Fn of t goes to F of t.
And that's just for any given t.
Is there any
question about this?
That averages converge
to expectation,
that's the law of large number.
And almost surely we
could say in probability
it's the same, that would be
the weak law of large number.
Now this is fine.
For any given t, the average
converges to the true.
It just happens that this
random variable is indexed by t,
and I could do it for
t equals 1 or 2 or 25,
and just check it again.
But I might want to check
it for all t's at once.
And that's actually
a different result.
That's called a
uniform result. I
want this to hold for
all t at the same time.
And it may be the case that it
works for each t individually
but not for all t's
at the same time.
What could happen is
that for t equals 1
it converges at a certain
rate, and for t equals 2
it converges at a
bit of a slower rate,
and for t equals 3 at a
slower rate and slower rate.
And so as t goes to infinity,
the rate is going to vanish
and nothing is
going to converge.
That could happen.
I could make this happen
at a finite point.
There's many ways where
it could make this happen.
Let's see how that could work.
I could say, well, actually no.
I still need to have this
at infinity for some reason.
It turns out that this
is still true uniformly,
and this is actually a much
more complicated result
than the law of large number.
It's called
Glivenko-Cantelli Theorem.
And the
Glivenko-Cantelli Theorem
tells me that, for all t's
at once, Fn converges to F.
So let me just show
you quickly why
this is just a little
bit stronger than the one
that we had.
If sup is confusing
you, think of max.
It's just the max
over an infinite set.
And so what we know is
that Fn of t goes to F of t
as n goes to infinity.
And that's almost surely.
And that's the law
of large numbers.
Which is equivalent to saying
that Fn of t minus F of t as n
goes to infinity converges
almost surely to 0, right?
This is the same thing.
Now I want this to happen
for all t's at once.
So what I'm going to do--
oh, and this is actually
equivalent to this.
And so what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to make it a little stronger.
So here the arrow
only goes one way.
And this is where the sup
for t in R of Fn of t.
And you could actually
show that this happens also
almost surely.
Now maybe almost
surely is a bit more
difficult to get a grasp on.
Does anybody want to see, like
why this statement for this sup
is strictly stronger than the
one that holds individually
for all t's?
You want to see that?
OK, so let's do that.
So forget about it almost
surely for one second.
Let's just do it in probability.
The fact that Fn of t
converges to F of t for all t,
in probability means that
this goes to 0 as n goes
to infinity for any epsilon.
For any epsilon in t
we know we have this.
That's the convergence
in probability.
Now what I want is
to put a sup here.
The probability that the
sup is lower than epsilon,
might be actually always
larger than, never go to 0
in some cases.
It could be the case
that for each given t,
I can make n large enough so
that this probability becomes
small.
But then maybe it's an n of t.
So this here means
that for any--
maybe I shouldn't put,
let me put a delta here.
So for any epsilon, for
any t and for any epsilon,
there exists n, which could
depend on both epsilon
and t, such that the
probability that Fn t
minus F of t exceeding delta
is less than epsilon t.
There exists an n and a delta.
No, that's for all delta, sorry.
So this is true.
That's what this limit
statement actually means.
But it could be the case that
now when I take the sup over t,
maybe that n of t is
something that looks like t.
Or maybe, well,
integer part of t.
It could be, right?
I don't say anything.
It's just an n
that depends on t.
So if this n is just t,
maybe t over epsilon,
because I want epsilon.
Something like this.
Well that means
that if I want this
to hold for all t's
at once, I'm going
to have to go for the n that
works for all t's at once.
But there's no such n that
The only n that
works is infinity.
And so I cannot make this
happen for all of them.
What Glivenko-Cantelli
tells you,
it's actually this is not
something that holds like this.
That the n that depends on t,
there's actually one largest n
that works for all the t's
at once, and that's it.
OK.
So just so you know why this is
actually a stronger statement,
and that's basically
how it works.
Any other question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what's
the position for this
to have, because the
random variable have
a finite mean, finite variance?
PROFESSOR: No.
Well the random variable
does have finite mean
and finite variance,
because the random variable
is an indicator.
So it has everything you want.
This is one of the
nicest random variables,
this is a Bernoulli
random variable.
So here when I say law of
large number, that this holds.
Where did I write this?
I think I erased it.
Yeah, the one over there.
This is actually the
law of large numbers
for Bernoulli random variables.
They have everything you want.
They're bounded.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm having
trouble understanding
the first statement.
So it says, for all
epsilon and all t,
the probability of that--
PROFESSOR: So you mean this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: For all
epsilon and all t.
So you fix them now.
Then the probability that,
sorry, that was delta.
I changed this epsilon
to delta at some point.
AUDIENCE: And then
what's the second line?
PROFESSOR: Oh, so then
the second line says that,
so I'm just rewriting in
terms of epsilon delta
what this n goes
to infinity means.
So it means that for
any a t and delta,
so that's the same
as this guy here,
then here I'm just going
back to rewriting this.
It says that for any epsilon
there exists an n large
enough such that, well,
n larger than this thing
basically, such that this
thing is less than epsilon.
So Glivenko-Cantelli tells us
that not only is this thing
a good idea pointwise, but it's
also a good idea uniformly.
And all it's saying
is if you actually
were happy with just
this result, you should
be even happier
with that result.
And both of those results
only tell you one thing.
They're just telling you
that the empirical CDF
is a good estimator of the CDF.
Now since those indicators
are Bernoulli distributions,
I can actually do even more.
So let me get this guy here.
OK so, those guys,
Fn of t, this guy
is a Bernoulli distribution.
What is the parameter of
this Bernoulli distribution?
What is the probability
that it takes value 1?
AUDIENCE: F of t.
PROFESSOR: F of t, right?
It's just the probability
that this thing happens,
which is F of t.
So in particular the
variance of this guy
is the variance
of this Bernoulli.
So it's F of t 1 minus F of t.
And I can use that in my
Central Limit Theorem.
And Central Limit
Theorem is just
going to tell me that
if I look at the average
of random variables,
I remove their mean,
so I look at square
root of n Fn of t,
which I could really
write as xn bar, right?
That's really just an xn bar.
Minus the expectation,
which is F
of t, that comes from this guy.
Now if I divide by square
root of the variance, that's
my square root p1 minus p.
Then this guy, by the
Central Limit Theorem,
goes to some N 0, 1.
Which is the same
thing as you see there,
except that the variance
was put on the other side.
OK.
Do I have the same
thing uniformly in t?
Can I write something
that holds uniformly in t?
Well, if you think
about it for one second
it's unlikely it's
going to go too well.
In the sense that it's
unlikely that the supremum
of those random variables over t
is going to also be a Gaussian.
And the reason is that,
well actually the reason
is that this thing is actually
a stochastic process indexed
by t.
A stochastic process is just
a sequence in random variables
that's indexed by,
let's say time.
The one that's the most
famous is Brownian motion,
and it's basically a bunch
of Gaussian increments.
So when you go from t to
just t a little after that,
you have add some
Gaussian into the thing.
And here it's basically the
same thing that's happening.
And you would sort of expect,
since each of this guy
is Gaussian, you
would expect to see
something that looks like a
Brownian motion at the end.
But it's not exactly
a Brownian motion,
it's something that's
called the Brownian bridge.
So if you've seen the
Brownian motion, if I make
it start at 0 for example,
so this is the value
of my Brownian motion.
Let's write it.
So this is one path, one
realization of Brownian motion.
Let's call it w of
t as t increases.
So let's say it starts at 0 and
looks like something like this.
So that's what Brownian
motion looks like.
It's just something
that's pretty nasty.
I mean it looks pretty nasty,
it's not continuous et cetera,
but it's actually very
benign in some average way.
So Brownian motion
is just something,
you should view this as if I
sum some random variable that
are Gaussian, and then I look at
this from farther and farther,
it's going to look like this.
And so here I cannot have
a Brownian motion in the n,
because what is the variance
of Fn of t minus F of t at t is
equal to 1?
Sorry, at t is
equal to infinity.
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: It's 0, right?
The variance goes from 0
at t is negative infinity,
because at negative infinity
F of t is going to 0.
And as t goes to
plus infinity, F of t
is going to 1, which means that
the variance of this guy as t
goes from negative
infinity to plus infinity
is pinned to be 0 on each side.
And so my Brownian
motion cannot,
when I describe a Brownian
motion I'm just adding more
and more entropy to the
thing and it's going all over
the place, but here what I want
is that as I go back it should
go back to essentially 0.
It should be pinned down to
a specific value at the n.
And that's actually called
the Brownian bridge.
It's a Brownian motion
that's conditioned
to come back to where
it started essentially.
Now you don't need to understand
Brownian bridges to understand
what I'm going to
be telling you.
The only thing I want
to communicate to you
is that this guy here, when
I say a Brownian bridge,
I can go to any probabilist
and they can tell you
all the probability properties
of this stochastic process.
It can tell me the
probability that it
takes any value at any point.
In particular, it can tell me--
the supremum between
0 and 1 of this guy,
it could tell me what the
cumulative distribution
function of this
thing is, can tell me
what the density of this thing
is, can tell me everything.
So it means that if I want
to compute probabilities
on this object here, which is
the maximum value that this guy
can take over a certain period
of time, which is basically
this random variable.
So if I look at the
value here, it's
a random variable
that fluctuates.
It can tell me where it is
with hyperability, can tell me
the quantiles of this
thing, which is useful
because I can build a table and
use it to compute my quantiles
and form tests from it.
So that's what
actually is quite nice.
It says that if I look at
the square root of n Fn
hat minus sup over
t, I get something
that looks like the
sup of these Gaussians,
but it's not really
sup of Gaussian,
it's sup of a Brownian motion.
Now there's something you
should be very careful here.
I cheated a little bit.
I mean, I didn't cheat,
I can do whatever I want.
But my notation might
be a little confusing.
Everybody sees that this t here
is not the same as this t here?
Can somebody see that?
Just because, first of all,
this guy's between 0 and 1.
And this guy is in all of R.
What is this t here?
As a function of this t here?
This guy is F of this guy.
So really, if I want it to
be completely transparent
and not save the
keys of my keyboard,
I would read this as sup
over t of Fn t minus F of t
goes to N distribution
as n goes to infinity.
The supremum over t,
again in R, so this guy is
for t in the entire
real line, this guy
is for t in the
entire real line.
But now I should
write b of what?
F of t, exactly.
So really the t here is
F of the original one.
And so that's a
Brownian bridge, where
when t goes to infinity
the Brownian bridge
goes from 0 to 1 and
it looks like this.
A Brownian bridge at
0 is 0, at 1 it's 0.
And it does this.
But it doesn't stray too
far because I condition
it to come back to this point.
That's what a
Brownian bridge is.
OK.
So in particular, I can find
a distribution for this guy.
And I can use this to build
a test which is called
the Kolmogorov-Smirnov test.
The idea is the following.
It says, if I want to
test some distribution
F0, some distribution that
has a particular CDF F0,
and I plug it in
under the null, then
this guy should have pretty
much the same distribution
as the supremum of
Brownian bridge.
And so if I see this to be
much larger than it should
be when it's the supremum
of a Brownian bridge,
I'm actually going to
reject my hypothesis.
So here's the test.
I want to test whether
H0, F is equal to F0,
and you will see that most
of the goodness of fit tests
are formulated
mathematically in terms
of the cumulative
distribution function.
I could formulate them in
terms of personality density
function, or just
write x follows N 0, 1,
but that's the way we write it.
We formulate them in terms
of cumulative distribution
function because
that's what we have
a handle on through the
empirical cumulative
distribution function.
And then it's versus H1,
F is not equal to F0.
So now I have my empirical CDF.
And I hope that for
all t's, Fn of t
should be close to F0 of t.
Let me write it like this.
I put it on the exponent
because otherwise that
would be the empirical
distribution function based
on zero observations.
Now I form the following
test statistic.
So my test statistic
is tn, which
is the supremum over t in
the real line of square root
of n Fn of t minus F
of t, sorry, F0 of t.
So I can compute everything.
I know this from
the data, and this
is the one that comes
from my null hypothesis.
As I can compute this thing.
And I know that if
this is true, this
should actually be the
supremum of a Brownian bridge.
Pretty much.
And so the Kolmogorov-Smirnov
test is simply,
reject if this guy,
tn, in absolute value,
no actually not
in absolute value.
This is just already
absolute valued.
Then this guy should be what?
It should be larger than the
q alpha over 2 distribution
that I have.
But now rather than
putting N 0, 1, or Tn,
this is here whatever
notation I have for supremum
of Brownian bridge.
Just like I did for any
pivotal distribution.
That was the same recipe
every single time.
I formed the test
statistic such that
the asymptotic distribution did
not depend on anything I know,
and then I would just reject
when this pivotal distribution
was larger than something.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm not really sure
why Brownian bridge appears.
PROFESSOR: Do you know what
a Brownian bridge is, or?
AUDIENCE: Only vaguely.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this thing here, think
of it as being a Gaussian.
So for all t you have a
Gaussian distribution.
Now a Brownian motion, so
if I had a Brownian motion
I need to tell you what the--
so it's basically
a Brownian motion
is something that
looks like this.
It's some random variable
that's indexed by t.
I want, say, the expectation
of Xt could be equal to 0
for all t.
And what I want is
that the increments
have a certain distribution.
So what I want is that the
expectation of Xt minus Xs
follows some distribution
which is N 0, t minus s.
So the increments are
bigger as I go farther,
in terms of variability.
And I also want some covariance
structure between the two.
So what I want is that the
covariance between Xs and Xt
is actually equal to
the minimum of s and t.
Yeah, maybe.
Yeah, that should be there.
So this is, you open a
probability book, that's
what it's going to look like.
So in particular, you
can see, if I put 0 here
and X0 is equal to
0, it has 0 variance.
So in particular,
it means that Xt,
if I look only at
the t-th one, it
has some normal distribution
with variance t.
So this is something
that just blows up.
So this guy here
looks like it's going
to be a Brownian
motion because when
I look at the left-hand side
it has a normal distribution.
Now there's a bunch of other
things you need to check.
It's the fact that you have
this covariance, for example,
which I did not tell you.
But it sure look
somewhat like that.
And in particular, when I
look at the normal with mean 0
and variance here,
then it's clear
that this guy does not
have a variance that's
going to go to infinity just
like the variance of this guy.
We know that the variance
is forced to be back to 0.
And so in particular
we have something
that has mean 0 always, whose
variance has to be 0 at 0,
and variance-- sorry, at t
equals negative infinity,
and variance 1 at t
equals plus infinity.
So a variance 0 at t
equals plus infinity,
and so I have to basically force
it to be equal to 0 at each n.
So the Brownian
motion here tends
to just go to
infinity somewhere,
whereas this guy
forces it to come back.
Now everything I
described to you
is on the scale negative
infinity to plus infinity,
but since everything
depends on F of t,
I can actually
just put that back
into a scale, which is 0 and 1
by a simple change of variable.
It's called change of time
for the Brownian motion.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does
a Brownian bridge
have a variance at each
point that's proportional?
Like it starts at
0 variance and then
goes to 1/4 variance
in the middle
and then goes back
to 0 variance?
Like in the same
parabolic shape?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean, definitely.
I mean by symmetry you can
probably infer all the things.
AUDIENCE: Well I can
imagine Brownian bridge
with a variance that starts
at 0 and stays, like,
the shape of the variance
as you move along.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so I
don't know if-- there
is an explicit formula
for this, and it's simple.
That's what I can tell you, but
I don't know what the explicit,
off the top of my head what
the explicit formula is.
AUDIENCE: But would it
have to match this F
of t 1 minus F of t structure?
Or not?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or does the fact that
we're taking the supremum--
PROFESSOR: No.
Well the Brownian bridge, this
is the supremum-- you're right.
So this will be this form
for the variance for sure,
because this is only
marginal distributions that
don't take-- right,
the process is not just
what is the distribution
at each instant t.
It's also how do those
distributions interact
with each other in
terms of covariance.
For the marginal distributions
at each instance t,
you're right, the variance
is F of t 1 minus F of t.
We're not going to escape that.
But then the covariance
structure between those guys
is a little more complicated.
But yes, you're right.
For marginal that's enough.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the supremum
of the Brownian bridge
is a number between 0
and 10, let's just say.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
could be infinity.
AUDIENCE: So it's not
symmetrical with respect to 0,
so why are we doing all over 2?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Did say raise it?
Yeah.
Because here I didn't say the
supremum of the absolute value
of a Brownian bridge, I
just said the supremum
of a Brownian bridge.
But you're right, let's
just do this like that.
And then it's probably cleaner.
So yeah, actually well
it should be q alpha.
So this is basically,
you're right.
So think of it as
being one-sided.
And there's actually no
symmetry for the supremum.
I mean the supremum is
not symmetric around 0,
so you're right.
I should not use alpha
over 2, thank you.
Any other question?
This should be alpha.
Yeah.
I mean those slides were
written with 1 minus alpha
and I have not replaced all
instances of 1 minus alpha
by alpha.
I mean, except this guy, tilde.
Well, depends on how
you want to call it.
But this is still, the
probability that Z exceeds
this guy should be alpha.
OK?
And this can be found in tables.
And we can compute the p-value
just like we did before.
But we have to simulate
it because it's not
going to depend on the
cumulative distribution
function of a Gaussian, like
it did for the usual Gaussian
test.
That's something that's
more complicated,
and typically you
don't even try.
You get the statistical
software to do it for you.
So just let me skip a few lines.
This is what the table looks
like for the Kolmogorov-Smirnov
test.
So it just tells you, what is
your number of observations, n.
Then you want alpha to
be equal to 5%, say.
Let's say you have
nine observations.
So if square root of n absolute
value of Fn of t minus F of t
exceeds this thing, you reject.
Well it's pretty
clear from this test
is that it looks
very nice, and I tell
you this is how you build it.
But if you think about
it for one second,
it's actually really
an annoying thing
to build because you have
to take the supremum over t.
This depends on computing a
supremum, which in practice
might be super cumbersome.
I don't want to have to
compute this for all values t
and then to take the
maximum of those guys.
It turns out that that's
actually quite nice that we
don't have to actually do this.
What does the empirical
distribution function
look like?
Well, this thing, remember
Fn of t by definition was--
so let me go to the
slide that's relevant.
So Fn of t looks like this.
So what it means is that when
t is between two observations,
then this guy is actually
keeping the same value.
So if I put my observations
on the real line here.
So let's say I have
one observation here,
and one observation here,
for simplicity.
Then this guy is basically,
up to this normalization,
counting how many observations
they have that are less than t.
So since I normalize by n, I
know that the smallest number
here is going to be 0, and
the largest number here
is going to be 1.
So let's say this
looks like this.
This is the value 1.
At the value, since I take
it less than or equal to,
when I'm at Xi, I'm
actually counting it.
So the jump happens at Xi.
So that's the first
observation, and then I jump.
By how much do I jump?
Yeah?
One over n, right?
And then this value
belongs to the right.
And then I do it again.
I know it's not going to work
out for me, but we'll see.
Oh no actually, I
did pretty well.
This is what my cumulative
distribution looks like.
Now if you look on
this slide, there
is this weird notation
where I start putting now
my indices in parentheses.
X parenthesis 1, X
parenthesis 2, et cetera.
Those are called the
ordered statistic.
It's just because it might
be, when my data is given
to me I just call the
first observation,
the one that's on
top of the table,
but it doesn't have to
be the smallest value.
So it might be that this
is X1 and that this is X2,
and then this is X3, X4, and X5.
These might be my observations.
So what I do is that I
call them in such a way
that this is actually,
I recall this guy X1,
which is just really X3.
This is X2, X3, X4, and X5.
These are my
reordered observations
in such a way that the
smallest one is indexed by one
and the largest one
is indexed by n.
So now this is
actually quite nice,
because what I'm trying to
do is to find the largest
deviation from this guy to the
true cumulative distribution
function.
The true cumulative
distribution function,
let's say it's Gaussian,
looks like this.
It's something continuous,
for a symmetric distribution
it crosses this axis at 1/2,
and that's what it looks like.
And the Kolmogorov-Smirnov
test is just
telling me how far do
those two curves get
in the worst possible case?
So in particular here,
where are they the farthest?
Clearly that's this point.
And so up to rescaling,
this is the value
I'm going to be interested in.
That's how they get as far
as possible from each other.
Here, something just
happened, right?
The farthest distance
that I got was exactly
at one of those dots.
It turns out this is enough
to look at those dots.
And the reason is, well
because after this dot
and until the next jump,
this guy does not change,
but this guy increases.
And so the only point where
they can be the farthest apart
is either to the left of a
jump or to the right of a jump.
That's the only place where
they can be far from each other.
And that means that
only one observation.
Everybody sees that?
The farthest points, the points
at which those two curves are
the farthest from
each other, has
to be at one of
the observations.
And so rather than looking at
a sup over all possible t's,
really all I need to do
is to look at a maximum
only at my observations.
I just need to check
at each of those points
whether they're far.
Now here, notice
that you did not,
this is not written Fn of Xi.
The reason is because I
actually know what Fn of Xi is.
Fn of the i-th order
observation is just
the number of jumps I've
had until this observation.
So here, I know that the
value of Fn is 1 over n,
here it's 2 over n, 3 over
n, 4 over n, 5 over n.
So I knew that the values
of Fn at my observations,
and those are actually the
only values that Fn can take,
are an integer divided by n.
And that's why you see i
minus 1 over n, or i over n.
This is the difference
just before the jump,
and this is the
difference at the jump.
So here the key message
is that this is no longer
a supremum over all
t's, but it's just
the maximum from 1 to n.
So I really have only
two n values to compute.
This value and this value for
each observation, that's 2n
total.
I look at the maximum and
that's actually the value.
And it's actually equal to tn.
It's not an approximation.
Those things are equal.
That's just the
only places where
those guys can be maximum.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It seems like since
the null hypothesis [INAUDIBLE]
the entire
distribution of theta,
this is like strictly
more powerful than just
doing it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's
strictly less powerful.
AUDIENCE: Strictly
less powerful.
But is there, is that
like a big trade-off
that we're making
when we do that?
Obviously we're not
certain in the first place
that we want to
assume normality.
Does it make sense
to [INAUDIBLE],,
the Gaussian [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So can
you, I'm not sure what
question you're asking.
AUDIENCE: So when we're
doing a normal test,
we're just asking
questions about the mus,
the means of our distribution.
[INAUDIBLE] This
one, it seems like it
would be both at the same time.
[INAUDIBLE] Is this
decreasing power [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: So remember,
here in this test
we want to conclude to H0, in
the other test we typically
want to conclude to H1.
So here we actually don't
want power, in a way.
And you have to also assume
that doing a test on the mean
is probably not the
only thing you're
going to end up
doing on your data
after you actually establish
that it's normally distributed.
Then you have the
dataset, you've sort of
established it's
normally distributed,
and then you can just run the
arsenal of statistical studies.
And we're going
to see regression
and all sorts of predictive
things, which are not just
tests if the mean is
equal to something.
Maybe you want to build
a confidence interval
for the mean.
Then this is not, confidence
interval is not a test.
So you're going to have to
first test if it's normal,
and then see if you
can actually use
the quantiles of a Gaussian
distribution or a t
distribution to build
this confidence interval.
So in a way you should do
this as like, the flat fee
to enter the Gaussian
world, and then you
can do whatever you want to
do in the Gaussian world.
We'll see actually that
your question goes back
to something that's a
little important, is here
I said F0 is fully specified.
It's like an N 1, 5.
But I didn't say, is it
normally distributed,
which is the question
that everybody asks.
You're not asking, is it this
particular normal distribution
with this particular mean
and this particular variance.
So how would you
do it in practice?
Well you would
say, I'm just going
to replace the mean by the
empirical mean and the variance
by the empirical variance.
But by doing that you're making
a huge mistake because you
are sort of depriving your
test of the possibility
to reject the Gaussian
hypothesis just
based on the fact that the
mean is wrong or the variance
is wrong.
You've already stuck to
your data pretty well.
And so you're sort
of like already
tilting the game in
favor of H0 big time.
So there's actually a
way to arrange for this.
OK, so this is about
pivotal statistic.
We've used this word many times.
And So that's how.
I'm not going to
go into this test.
It's really, this is a recipe
on how you would actually
build the table that I
showed you, this table.
This is basically the
recipe on how to build it.
There's another recipe to
build it, which is just
open a book at this page.
That's a little faster.
Or use software.
I just wanted to show you.
So let's just keep in mind,
anybody has a good memory?
Let's just keep in
mind this number.
This is the threshold for the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov statistic.
If I have 10 observations
and I want to do it at 5%,
it's about 41%.
So that's the number that
it should be larger from.
So it turns out that if you want
to test if it's normal, and not
just the specific
normal, this number
is going to be different.
Do you think the
number I'm going
to read in a table that's
appropriate for this is
going to be larger or smaller?
Who says larger?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what
was the question?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, this
is the number I should see if
my test was, is X, say, N 0, 5.
Right?
That's a specific distribution
with a specific F0.
So that's the
number, I would build
the Kolmogorov-Smirnov
statistic from this.
I would perform a test and
check if my Kolmogorov-Smirnov
statistic tn is larger
than this number or not.
If it's larger I'm
going to reject.
Now I say, actually, I don't
want to test if H0 is N 0, 5,
but it's just a mu sigma squared
for some mu and sigma squared.
And in particular I'm just
going to plugin mu hat and sigma
hat into my F0, run
the same statistic,
but compare it to
a different number.
So the larger the
number, the more or less
likely am I to reject?
The less likely I
am to reject, right?
So if I just use that
number, let's say
this is a large
number, I would be more
tempted to say it's Gaussian.
And if you look at
the table you would
get that if you make the
appropriate correction
at the same number
of observations, 10,
and the same level, you
get 25% as opposed to 41%.
That means that you're actually
much more likely if you
use the appropriate test to
reject the fact that it's
normal, which is bad
news, because that means
you don't have access
to the Gaussian arsenal,
and nobody wants to do this.
So actually this is a
mistake that people do a lot.
They use the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test
to test for normality without
adjusting for the fact
that they've plugged
in the estimated mean
and the estimated variance.
This leads to rejecting
less often, right?
I mean this is almost half
of the number that we had.
And then they can be
happy and walk home
and say, well, I did the
test and it was normal.
So this is actually
a mistake that I
believe that genuinely at
least a quarter of the people
do make in purpose.
They just say, well I want
it to be Gaussian so I'm just
going to make my life easier.
So this is the so-called
Kolmogorov Lilliefors test.
We'll talk about it,
well not today for sure.
There's other statistics that
you can test, that you can use.
And the idea is to
say, well, we want
to know if the
empirical distribution
function, the empirical CDF,
is close to the true CDF.
The way we did it is by
forming the difference
in looking at the worst
possible distance they can be.
That's called a sup
norm, or L infinity norm,
in functional analysis.
So here, this is
what it looked like.
The distance between Fn and
F that we measured was just
the supremum distance
over all t's.
That's one way to measure
distance between two functions.
But there's an
infinite many ways
to measure distance
between functions.
One is something we're
much more familiar with,
which is the squared L2-norm.
This is nice because this
has like an inner product,
it has some nice properties.
And you could actually just,
rather than taking the sup,
you could just integrate
the squared distance.
And this is what leads to
Cramier-Von Mises test.
And then there's
another one that
says, well, maybe I don't want
to integrate without weights.
Maybe I want to put weights
that account for the variance.
And this guy is called
Anderson-Darling.
For each of these
tests you can check
that the asymptotic distribution
is going to be pivotal,
which means that there will be
a table at the back of some book
that tells you what the
statistic, the quantiles
of square root of
n times this guy
are asymptotically, basically.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test,
for the table that
shows the value it has,
it has the value
for different n.
But I thought we [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's just to show you that
asymptotically it's pivotal,
and I can point you
to one specific thing.
But it turns out that this thing
is actually pivotal for each n.
And that's why you have this
recipe to construct the entire
thing, because it's actually
not true for all possible n's.
Also there's the n
that shows up here.
So no actually,
this is something
you should have in mind.
So basically, let me
strike what I just said.
This thing you can
actually, this distribution
will not depend on F0
for any particular n.
It's just not going to
be a Brownian bridge
but a finite sample
approximation of a Brownian
bridge, and you can simulate
that just drawing samples
from it, building a
histogram, and constructing
the quantiles for this guy.
AUDIENCE: No one has
actually developed
a table for Brownian--
PROFESSOR: Oh, there is one.
That's the table, maybe.
Let's see if we see it at the
bottom of the other table.
Yeah.
See?
Over 40, over 30.
So this is not the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov,
but that's the
Kolmogorov Lilliefors.
Those numbers that
you see here, they
are the numbers for the
asymptotic thing which is
some sort of Brownian bridge.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
If I want to build the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test,
it says that F0 is
required to be continuous.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] If
we have, like, probability
mass of a particular value.
Like some sort of data.
PROFESSOR: So then you won't
have this nice picture, right?
This can happen at any
point because you're
going to have
discontinuities in F
and those things can
happen everywhere.
And then--
AUDIENCE: Would the
supremum still work?
PROFESSOR: You mean
the Brownian bridge?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The Kolmogorov test
doesn't say that you
have to be able to easily
calculate the supremum.
PROFESSOR: No, no, no,
but you still need it.
You still need it for--
so there's some finite
sample versions of it
that you can use that are
slightly more conservative,
which is in a way good
news because you're
going to conclude more to H0.
And there's are some,
I forget the name,
it's Kiefer-Wolfowitz, the
Kiefer-Dvoretzky-Wolfowitz,
an equality which is basically
like Hoeffding's inequality.
So it's basically
up to bad constants
telling you the same result
as the Brownian bridge result,
and those are true all the time.
But for the exact
asymptotic distribution,
you need continuity.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So just
a clarification.
So when we are testing
the Kolmogorov,
we shouldn't test a particular
mu and sigma squared?
PROFESSOR: Well if you know
what they are you can use
Kolmogorov-Smirnov, but if
you don't know what they are
you're going to plug in--
as soon as you're
going to estimate
the mean and the
variance from the data,
you should use the one we'll
see next time, which is
called Kolmogorov Lilliefors.
You don't have to think
about it too much.
We'll talk about it on Thursday.
Any other question?
So we're out of time.
So I think we should stop here,
and we'll resume on Thursday.